abordemos este ejemplo de
espectrofotometría tomado con el permiso
de kotz rico y tan sin autores del libro
química y reactividad química veamos de
qué se trata el problema nos dice que es
una solución de permanganato de potasio
voy a delinear lo de un color obscuro
cuya absorban cya es de 0.500 39 cuando
se mide a 540 nanómetros en una celda de
un centímetro
estos 540 nanómetros
son la longitud de onda a la que se
midió la absorban cya probablemente sea
la longitud de onda a la que se da una
buena absorción por el permanganato de
potasio es decir que se detectara
fácilmente la concentración de la
solución ok y la celda es de un
centímetro
esta es la longitud
cuál es la concentración del
permanganato de potasio
antes de determinar la absorban cya de
la solución desconocida se obtuvieron
los siguientes datos de calibración para
el espectrofotómetro estas son las
absorban cias medidas a concentraciones
conocidas entonces usaremos estos datos
y después localizaremos esta absorbencia
sobre la línea de la ley de bird lambert
aprendimos que hay un comportamiento
lineal entre la observancia y la
concentración por lo que ésta absorban
cya se encontrará en algún punto de esa
línea y sólo tendremos que leer la
concentración nuestra concentración
desconocida entonces primero graphic
hemos estos datos pondré nuestro eje de
concentración
bajaré la página para que se puedan ver
los datos y se pueda ver la gráfica
lo trataré de dibujar y que no me quedé
tan chueco
el eje horizontal será de la
concentración molar
concentración
lleva de 0.03 a 0.15
por aquí está el 0.03
3 cuadritos después estás 0.06 123 aquí
está 0.09 este es 0.12 y éste es 0.15 y
luego la absorban cya cerca de cero
bueno 0.1 que éste sea 0.1
este es 0.2
0.3
0.4
0.5 ya casi acabamos 0.6
0.7
0.8 y 0.9 cubre todos los valores de
absorbencia que tenemos aquí vamos con
el primero cuando tenemos una
concentración de permanganato de potasio
0.03 molar 0.03 la absorban cya es de
0.16 2 aquí esta 0.03 y 0.1 aquí es 0.15
entonces 0.16 queda por aquí
y luego cuando tenemos una modalidad de
0.06 la absorban cya fue de 0.33
entonces a 0.06 punto 33 están es 3.35
entonces punto 33 está por aquí ya
empezamos a ver la línea pero sigamos
graficando los puntos 0.09 molar tenemos
0 punto 499 casi punto 5 por aquí y
luego a 0.12 tenemos 0.67 de absorban
cya apuntó 12 este es el punto 65
entonces punto 67 está por acá
con esto estamos demostrando que la ley
debe ir lambert es verdad obtuvimos la
absorbencia de un montón de
concentraciones específicas y obtuvimos
un comportamiento lineal gráfica hemos
el último punto 15 0.15 la absorban
cyaes de 0.84 este es punto 15.84 está
por acá
aquí se ve el comportamiento lineal
trataré de dibujar la línea
esta es en efecto la ley de bird lambert
ahora regresemos a nuestro problema
sabemos que una solución de
concentración misteriosa tiene una
absorbencia de 0.50 y 30 punto 539 la
absorban cya si por aquí queda 0.55
entonces 0.50 y 39 está por aquí justo
aquí y queremos saber la concentración
del permanganato de potasio bueno si
seguimos la ley de bird lambert
simplemente bajamos en esta línea y esta
concentración es de aproximadamente
punto 1 molar es sólo una estimación
pero parece que es punto 1 molar para
esa solución esa es la respuesta a
nuestra pregunta usando los datos de la
tabla pero tratemos de ser más exactos
conocemos la ley de bird lambert la cual
nos dice que la observancia es igual a
una constante por la longitud por la
concentración la longitud está dada en
centímetros y la concentración está en
moles por litro polaridad entonces
podemos calcular
de hecho basados en alguno de estos
puntos sabemos que a una concentración 0
la absorban cya será 0 entonces con
alguno de estos puntos podemos saber
cuál es el valor exacto de la constante
sabemos sabemos que todos estos datos
están en la misma longitud o al menos
eso estoy suponiendo todo se metió en
las celdas de un centímetro
esa es la longitud que la luz tiene que
recorrer en este ejemplo nuestra
longitud es igual a un centímetro veamos
si podemos calcular esta constante pared
permanganato de potasio creo que todos
se encuentran a condiciones normales de
presión y temperatura para esta longitud
de onda que nos dan de 540 nanómetros si
tomamos el primer punto tomaré el
primero
la absorbencia fue de 0.16 2 y esto es
igual a esta constante de
proporcionalidad por un centímetro por
cual es la concentración
bueno la absorbencia de 0.16 2
corresponde a la concentración de 0.03
por 0.0300 para usar más cifras y
queremos resolver esto para conocer la
etsi lo podemos simplemente dividir toda
la ecuación entre 0.0300 ambos lados
entre 0.0300 y que nos queda
estos se cancelan y nos queda que
epsilon es igual a usemos la calculadora
punto 16 2 / 0.03 es igual a 5.4 y como
estamos usando al menos 3 cifras
significativas esto es 5 punto 4 05.40 y
podemos dividir ambos lados entre 1 para
obtener las unidades ahora podemos usar
esto para saber la respuesta exacta a
nuestro problema no solo a simple vista
como lo hicimos por acá sabemos que para
el permanganato de potasio y a 540
nanómetros la absorban cya es igual a
5.4 x
pondré las unidades para que no nos
confundamos la constante está en litros
por centímetro mar y como pueden ver se
cancelan los centímetros con los de la
longitud y esto con la polaridad que es
moles por litro nos queda que la
absorban cya esa dimensional sin
unidades
entonces en nuestro ejemplo la longitud
es de un centímetro un centímetro y esto
multiplica la concentración esa
concentración desconocida que tenemos
que calcular en nuestro ejemplo nos
dicen que la absorban cya fue de 0.5 39
0.5 39 y esto es igual a 5.4 litros por
centímetro mol
por un centímetro
por nuestra concentración los
centímetros se cancelan este centímetro
se cancela con este y podemos
simplemente dividir ambos lados entre
5.4 litros por moll dividamos ambos
lados entre 5.4 litros por mol
y que nos queda del lado derecho todo
esto se cancela y solo me queda la
concentración nuestra concentración es
igual a calculemos a cuánto equivale
esto
tenemos 0.5 39 / 5.4 bueno 5.40 y esto
es igual a cero punto 0 99 83 cifras
significativas esto es igual a 0.09 98
y si dividimos entre litros formol queda
como moles / litro moles / litro
hemos sido capaces de obtener una
respuesta más exacta usando la ecuación
haciendo uso de las matemáticas
obtuvimos una respuesta más exacta a la
que habíamos obtenido de forma gráfica
aquí usando la gráfica y los datos de la
tabla obtuvimos un resultado pero de
forma matemática obtuvimos un resultado
más exacto de las dos maneras obtuvimos
una respuesta muy buena usando la
gráfica obtuvimos un resultado de 0.1
molar y usando la ecuación matemática
obtuvimos 0.09 98 y esto es muy cercano
a lo que estimamos usando los datos de
la tabla usando la gráfica 0.1 es un
poquitito más de 0.09 98
espero que lo hayan disfrutado